when you
were optimizing for trying to set the
world record in 100 miler
were you doing like analysis of
maybe like what were the variables you
were looking at
is it more in the realm of the actual
race day
the track what it looks like versus like
the variables of the training leading up
to the
to the race i mean it evolved a bit like
i think the
as i learned more about just like what
is required
to kind of really do that stuff so
there's some variables you can control
for
you know i try to control for as many as
i can the big one that kind of stands
out that you can't necessarily control
for
is it's pretty rare where you get an
event where they're just doing 100 miles
on a track it's usually
like uh like an event of like a series
of different events where there might be
like
some people out there doing 50k some
people out there doing 24 or something
like the event i did that there's six
day folks out there they're trying to
see how far they get in six days so you
have like this
much wider range of pacing just due to
like the distance
so you know track protocol is always
like
you pass on the outside so if you're
running
one of the faster paces of the day um
which when you're going up to six days
you're gonna and you're doing 100 miles
you're probably going to be running
faster than most people out there
then you know you just end up running
more because you end up running in lane
two around the turns unless sometimes
lane three around the turns
so it's down to those little details
that have a big impact yep so i had to
build that into my pacing strategy i
also have to build into the pacing
strategy like
relative non-moving time uh you know i
did a race just recently
i was the us track and field hundred
mile road championships and i did not
stop once other than like i guess i
technically stopped like
in the aid station for like a few
seconds to like grab bottles and
get myself wet because it was like 94
degrees that day but
i didn't like stop at all during that
race from like
what i would say is like a long period
of time where we're getting up to like a
minute
but that's pretty rare even on the track
like when i ran 11 hours and 19 minutes
uh i think i stopped three times for
maybe a total of like i believe
i have to look back for sure but i think
it was like three to four minutes or
something like that so you gotta you
gotta
figure that into your pacing strategy
especially if you're chasing a specific
time
because you know if i'm pacing for you
know at the time the world record was 11
28 um so if i'm pacing for say
11 27 30 or something like that and i
don't account for that
three minutes of stoppage then i might
run the exact pace i had planned on but
then i'm a minute off of the world
record
so 11 28 we're talking about 11 hours
we're talking about 100 miles
can you mention what the world record
was what uh
what kind of world record you said can
you tell your own story here
of uh of what you were able to
accomplish that world record that i
broke actually just recently got rebroke
um by a guy
um over in lithuania uh alexa sorkin
um phenomenal race i mean he's he's won
the 24-hour world championships he's won
the spartathlon which is another big
historic
ultra marathon rates 153 miles so it's
getting a little more lengthy than
some of the stuff that i've
traditionally done um he ran 11 14
i believe it was 56 or 57. um so his
pace was 645 per mile mine was 647 and a
half
in terms of just like the pacing
strategy it's it's just really cool
because
for me the motivation
with chasing the world record was it was
multifaceted i think there was
as i kind of moved through because i
mean it took me almost six years from
the day i decided i wanna chase that
time
to the day i actually did it uh and
through that
five to six years i think i emerged from
just like my
number one goal was to try to break the
world record to my number one goal is
how fast can i run this thing and then
ultimately
um what needs to be done for a human to
break 11 hours and 100 miles because i
think that's gonna be
i think that's gonna happen wow soon i
think it's gonna happen
in the next few years would that be um
sub 11 would be i think like i
think it's like 6 35 right about per
mile you're moving
quick but not so quick that like you're
you're you know void of being able to
think about everything as it's happening
so what's the pace in terms of if you
look
for each of the one mile segments
for the 100 miles is it pretty steady
six like in order to break 11 hours
would it be pretty steady 635 does it go
up and down do you speed up at the very
end
like what's what's the pacing if you
were to and maybe how much variability
is there in the pacing
yep for an optimal performance here yeah
so if you're talking about someone let's
say that there's someone well let's just
take me for example let's say that we
could just like
we had this infinite knowledge and we
knew for a fact
a perfect performance for me would
produce a 1059 but i'm not going a
second faster
and i need to do everything right in
order to run a 1059. uh
i would definitely want to either have a
slight negative or a slight positive
split
so when um and i think there's i think
there's uh
there's a range in there where like
being a little bit faster the first half
the second half isn't going to
necessarily
change your outcome or being a little
bit slower the first half
and a little bit faster the second half
isn't going to drastically change your
outcome
so that's what you're referring to the
split is you're looking at the first 50
miles in the second 15 miles
and you can break it down as as tiny as
you want like i think uh
when you take out the outlier laps where
i stopped to use the bathroom which
would have been that like three to four
minute non-moving time that i talked
about before
my splits were really tight um i had a
couple that were
um it was weird because that that track
that i did that on was actually like
400 and some weird number like 438
meters or something like that so
i actually like ran like my numbers
based on that so they're
they're normally i'm dealing with 400
meters and then it's a little more like
clean as to like what my lap splits
are going to range from one event to the
next so we're talking about running 100
miles on a track
yeah and so that you can be really
scientific about yes getting the
the the the um the pacing right
and uh you're you're running on the
inside lane or
is there some kind of tricks to this
like are you alternating
directions yeah they'll switch
directions at most events every four
hours
so you'll do four hours one way and then
they usually put a cone out
and once it hits like like let's say it
hits four hours
you finish the lap you're on and then
you do a loop around and then you start
the next your next laptop would you say
you take the exact same number of steps
like when you're really in the groove
when you're taking the pacing
are we talking about that level of
precision or is it a little bit more
feel you mean like foot strike frequency
yeah like
frequency then over the distance to the
lap would you say it's so precise that
you're like you get in this groove where
it's like perfect yeah
gosh you're making me wish i would have
strapped more like a foot pod to mine
but like yeah so i think like my guess
is it's pretty precise like it's
is there a video of this sorry i keep
interrupting is there video of this
because
i i've actually this is now three years
ago build a computer vision
algorithm that counts foot strikes oh
really yeah for fun
yeah i was trying to understand uh we'll
talk about that we have the same
definition of fun when
i've got my find myself on a track for
all day and you find yourself counting
foot strikes
i was trying to understand if if there's
how much variability there's
in uh extreme like elite performers
within a particular race but also across
races it was just interesting to me
from a robotics perspective if like
how much variability there is in the
human body in in the way they use legs
to move
quickly i think my guess would be that
at the individual level it's going to be
pretty precise assuming the pacing
is consistent so you get so my pacing
on that day i ran two minutes faster the
second 50 miles and i did the first 50
miles so my splits were very even most
of the day
i actually ran some of my fastest miles
at the end uh so
there's going to be probably a slight
variance from my fastest mile to my
slowest mile in
like your cadence or your foot strike uh
but probably not by a huge margin but
you might have a pretty big variance
from one person to the next
so you get someone whose gait is just a
little bit different so like for me
i supinate which means i kind of come
down on the outside of my foot
and i'm kind of more of a mid forefoot
striker so that's going to kind of
impact my cadence
to a degree whereas you might have
someone who is kind of more
mid to rear of their foot or heel
striker and they might pronate where
their foot kind of rolls in
so that person may have a little bit of
a different cadence as well so
you get someone and i think you see this
in elite marathoning too which is going
to probably
just be a much larger data pool uh much
much more probably precise from just
like a number of opportunities to study
this
and i think even their ranges from one
person the next can be
i wouldn't say drastic but you know to
the degree of like
10 to maybe even 20 steps per minute or
something like that from one person to
the next
but most people the faster they go the
higher their cadence is going to be the
slower they go the lower their cadence
is going to be
but there's going to be probably a range
of optimal
lowness and i don't know what probably
optimal
highness too than that
you